I'm sure you've asked a lot of questions
during your life you probably asked a
bunch of questions when you were a kid
why do I have to eat brussel sprouts
where do babies come from why can't I
stick this fork in that light socket and
sometimes you'd get a quick answer other
times you'd be told to ask someone else
ask your mother ask your teacher over
time you found out that your mother and
your teacher didn't have all of the
answers to Life's questions so maybe you
tried to find someone who knew more
eventually you may have asked an expert
but even if you find an expert you'll
soon realize that experts don't have all
the answers either why don't they have
all the answers it's simple if you think
about everything that can possibly be
known past present and future about the
universe about all of reality science
mathematics history ethics theology all
all possible knowledge how much of what
can be known does any brilliant college
professor actually know not much
probably a very very tiny percentage so
it's easy to keep asking questions until
even an expert doesn't know the
answers but we understand what it means
to know a tiny fraction of everything
that can be known and we understand that
someone can know more than others so if
we continue thinking about what it would
be like to know more and more and more
we find that there's an upper
limit what if someone knew absolutely
everything that would be omniscience and
the possessor of that knowledge would be
what we call
God wouldn't it be nice to ask God the
ultimate expert on everything a question
you've asked a lot of questions during
your life unless you stop asking
questions very early on you probably
didn't get answers to a lot of your
questions and now it's time for you to
ask one more question so if you could
ask God one question and you knew that
God would answer that one question what
one question would you
ask I'd like you to post your question
for God in the comments you don't get to
ask two questions well you can do
whatever you want but if you post more
than one question I'm going to ignore it
because I'm specifically trying to
figure out what people regard as the
single most important answer they'd like
to have so one question I'll explain why
later this will be interesting I'd also
like you to give a thumbs up a like to
any other questions that people ask that
you think are really good questions so
that we can start to get a rank of the
most important questions people have now
I'm sure some of you Dawkins drones are
about to comment haha I don't even
believe in God so why would I ask a
question to someone who doesn't exist
LOL I don't believe in a cosmic wizard I
don't need a sky daddy prove to me that
God
exists and stop embarrassing yourself
even if you believe that God is a
fictional character you can still think
of a question you would ask a fictional
character when you're playing Dungeons
and Dragons don't you ask the red dragon
oh red dragon how can I too be the most
archetypal villain of Legend and
Fable someone could say to me David
suppose you could ask Sherlock Holmes
any question what would you ask Sherlock
Holmes is a fictional character but I'd
be happy to ask him Mr Holmes
why would people who according to their
own worldview only have at best another
60 or 70 years of life spend every
waking moment whining about religion in
the comment section of
YouTube so even if you don't believe
that God exists you can still write down
a question that you would ask God if he
existed all right that's the assignment
everyone no matter what your beliefs
happen to be can ask one question
question if you ask more than one
question your questions will be ignored
but be sure to give a thumbs up to any
questions that you think are especially
good
questions and in the words of count
rugan and remember this is for posterity
so be
[Music]
honest